All the people who are currently in France or Europe,
who are experiencing precarious situations,
who have no papers.
Honestly,
hats off to you because it's not easy,
you are strong in the head and that's what you need in France here.
If you're not strong in the head it will knock you out.
We think the most important thing is to return to France,
but it's not just that.
When you come back to France,
how did you get to France?
There?
It will determine if you get paper quickly or not.
And that's what we didn't understand.
When we were in the country,
we wanted to come to France here,
we were looking for all the possible options because for us,
the most important thing was really to return to France.
But today,
I understood that the first fight,
even there,
is when you arrive in France because you will die either by water or by aiming
You will go through a lot of situations,
you will return to France,
but 1 time that you are in France there you will start in the first days,
go make your photos,
show that you are in France but the after the after yes you are in France And
then one of the hardest countries to have paper,
France Already even when you have the papers in France here your head suffers.
Who imagines someone who doesn't have the papers I myself have
been undocumented for several years I will share my experience with you,
I will share my adventure with you.
Maybe it will help other people.
In any case,
tell me in comments if this is 1 topic to discuss on my page here,
we will exchange.
If you know people who are undocumented,
come We will discuss from time to time on my page here,
whether it is in comment or in DM I will also often do live broadcasts to talk about
this subject because it is 1 subject that has marked me.
In any case all people who are in an irregular situation.
I tell you my hat because I know it's not.
1 easy situation.